- One topic where I
regularly get questions
from you is networking.
Many people believe that
being good at networking
is essential to land that high
profile job like consulting,
investment banking, or a big corporate.
Though in my experience,
there is a wide misconception
when it comes to networking
and this is exactly what I'm
going to talk about today.
I will tell you why most people
have networking all wrong
and I will tell you how instead
you should use networking
to really make it benefit your career.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich.
I am a former consultant at
McKinsey and at Accenture
and on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
On my channel, I want to pass
on the experience that I have
from working and consulting at McKinsey
and also at other companies
throughout my career.
Recently I asked for video suggestions
on my Instagram page, firmlearning,
and many of you asked me
to talk about networking.
There really is this
perception that networking
is a crucial component
of doing your job hunt,
of getting the dream
job that you wanna get.
I know that people invest a
lot of time on career events
and similar activities like that
just to get in contact
with the HR professionals
who are actual other
employees of the companies
that you are interested to join.
And I was on the receiving
side of this as well.
So, on several instances,
I attended career events as faculty.
So, as a consultant of the firm,
but then just organized and
conducted the career event
and as you can imagine,
during the social phases of
that event, for instance,
during the evening so then later,
also the night outs that
are often being organized,
all the attendees and
participants would contact you
as a consultant.
Of course, a lot try to get
you into a conversation,
ask you about your job,
ask about the careers,
asking you whether you could help them
to get the interview to get in.
And this, of course, is perfectly normal.
This is perfectly okay.
I behaved like that as well
when I was a candidate
trying to land a job.
That being said, I do think that there is
a major misperception
of many of these people
who attend these events are engaged
in similar networking activities.
And this misperception is that if you,
as a candidate, manage
to make a good impression
on the HR professional, on the consultant
attending these events,
then they would help you
to get the interview, to get invited,
just because they like you so much.
So, pretty much believing that
networking is a door opener
that helps you to get in, to get the job,
to get into the interview.
But, I can tell you that this is wrong.
This is not how it works.
And while, of course, there might always
be individual exceptions,
in general, you will not get invited
to the interview only because
on any of these events,
you made a good impression
on the HR professional
or on a consultant just in
a personal conversation.
The leading consulting firms,
and I trust many other firms as well,
have very strong processes in place
to prevent that people just get invited
to the interview due to
personnel relations in the firm.
Only because your best buddy
is a consultant working
with one of these firms,
this alone will not get you in
and if you don't believe me,
just think about it, right?
How does the whole process works?
Because you send in your
application documents.
And then, of course, we go through
a pretty solid review process.
As you can imagine, in most regions,
there are lots of HR professionals
who screen these CVs.
You can by no means assume
that the HR professional
that you talked will actually be the one
who screens your CV.
Even if that professional does allow you
to directly send your documents
to that person instead of
the regular online process,
still this does not regularly mean
that this person will also be the one
who in the end screens your
CV and decides on your case.
And besides that, also put yourself
in the shoes of these people.
These ladies and gents attend these kinds
of events every other day
and every single time
they will be approached
by a whole bunch of candidates,
a whole bunch of interests
that people who just will try
to make a conversation with them.
Will try to talk to them.
Will try to make an impression on them.
Even if you do your
very best and do indeed
have a good conversation with that person,
how high do you think
your chances really are
that you will make a lasting
impression on that individual?
Why this might not be impossible,
this for sure shouldn't be
something that you trust you will
be accomplishing in these meetings.
And the same is true for the consultants.
So, not necessarily the HR professionals,
but the consultants who just
often also attend these events.
These guys will be even farther away
from the actual decision
process, because first of all,
they're usually not involved at all
in screening CVs of candidates.
So, they will usually
have no leverage to help
you get through the CV screening process.
But, what if you don't manage
to get through the CV screening
and get into the interviews?
Because there indeed it is
true that these are conducted
by actual consultants.
But, the chance that
you will be interviewed
by the same consultant
that you randomly meet
on one of these events
will be super small,
at least in a large office like Germany,
they're literally hundreds of consultants
doing these interviews,
you by no means will have the
certainty that this would then
also be the guy who does
the interview with you.
So, I hope that by now
we're on the same page
and this perception that many people have,
that if you network you will get invited
to interview and that also
help you then get the job
that this in most instances is wrong
and for sure is wrong
for MBB consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
Still, my view on that is not
that there is no value in networking.
I believe there is a very specific place
of networking in your application journey
and for this reason,
I actually think that it is quite crucial
and quite important for most candidates
to engage in some kind
of networking activities
of the like that I've just described.
So, to better understand what
networking actually is for
in the whole recruiting process,
is to understand what
actually most people struggle
with most when they try to
land this high-profile job
that we're all looking out for.
So, when I talk to people who prepare
for their consulting interviews,
many of them tell me, well, you know,
I practiced all of these cases.
I learned all of these
frameworks by heart.
I know exactly what to say in
these interviews and so on.
And, of course, this is important
and this is crucial to
get the interview right.
But still, from my experience
when working with candidates
the number one reason that
holds people back really
is the mindset.
Many people, if you really have
a heart-to-heart conversation with them,
we'll tell you that they actually believe
that they are not good enough
for a job at an MBB consulting firm.
The criteria that are often
also communicated by these firms
that you need to meet to
get in sometimes seems
so difficult to reach.
They seem so elusive
that people just believe
that no way they are good
enough, no way they can do it,
no way they have what it
takes to become a consultant
in one of these large consulting firms
or to get into that
other high profile career
that they actually would like to.
And this, of course, is a huge problem.
If you are not convinced
that you are good enough,
how are you supposed to put together a CV
that can convince anybody else
that you are the right person for the job?
If you lack the confidence
that you would be a great fit
to work at McKinsey, BCG, or Bain,
how will you convince
your interviewer of this?
To get yourself ready
for these interviews,
to give yourself a chance
to get into these jobs,
you need to work on your mindset first.
You need to build that confidence.
You need to build that
conviction, that yes,
you have a good and
solid chance to get in.
That yes, you would be able to do the job,
that you would be in a
position to add value
at a consulting team or whatever company
you would fancy to get in.
And this is now where from my experience,
networking can play a crucial
role in the whole process.
On these events,
you have the opportunity to talk
to these real consultants, to
real employees of these firms
and if you have a good
conversation with them,
you have the opportunity to realize
that they are actually very normal,
very down to earth people.
They are not that different,
probably from any friends
that you also surround yourself with.
They are not that different from you.
They also studied at a
university probably not
that different to yours, they're
have probably good grades.
Not everybody is in the
top 3% of their class
who joined one of these firms.
They are not people from another planet.
There are people like you.
You can be one of these guys as well.
And the more you talk to these people,
the easier it will be for
you to understand this
and to really get this into your head
and it will hopefully enable
you to come to the conclusion
that yes, it could be you as well.
You could do this job as well.
There is nothing that these people have
that you don't have as well,
because indeed here, the truth is,
everybody's just cooking with water.
Indeed there is no magic ingredient.
And sometimes indeed these
firms can be quite good
at making you feel like it
is this way, but in the end,
trust me from experience,
you don't need to have
an IQ of 150 plus to be able to do the job
and to do a good job at it.
So, use networking events
to really understand
what the reality of working in
one of these firms look like,
how the people are that you
might surround yourself with
there in the future.
And use this as a reflection for yourself.
Can you be one of these guys as well?
Do you want to be one
of these guys as well?
Is this a job that would
really interest you
and that you do believe
that you can add value.
And with this conviction,
I trust that interviews
will be much easier for you
and also trust that this
will significantly help you
to come up with a strong CV.
And frankly in the end,
this is also a big part of
what I try to accomplish
with my channel as well.
I hope that with my videos
I make it more transparent
what it actually looks like
to be a consultant also
in one of these high profile firms.
And I do hope that you
realize that actually
I am not that different
than many of you guys
and I trust that many of
you would be very well able
to do this job as well if you, of course,
want to do it in the end.
So, I hope this does make sense to you.
And as always, if you have any question,
leave me a comment below
in the comment section
and please be aware that
if you write the comment,
not only will I do my best to provide you
with an insightful answer,
but you're really supporting
me with the YouTube algorithm
because a video with lots of comments
always looks great to the system.
And in addition, if you took any value out
of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And please also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
And please also turn
on the notification bay
because otherwise YouTube might
not show you all my videos,
even if you are subscribed to me.
If you want to see even more from me,
you can also follow me on my Instagram
my handle is firmlearning and
I also have a mailing list.
There is a signup link to that below
in the video description.
Now, I wanna take a
moment to say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a
considerable contribution
to my work.
I very much appreciate that.
And if you would consider
becoming a member as well,
there's a join button next
to the subscribe button.
If you click it, you
will get all the details
and also learn about
all the membership perks
that you will get only as a member.
So again, thank you for watching.
I really, really appreciate that.
I feel privileged that I have
the opportunity to communicate
to so many of you via my channel.
Here on Firm Learning I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So, see you again one week
from now and until then,
good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Bye bye.